this is a cross product sega mega-cd
development kit it's for making mega CD
games it's date stamped 1992 which will
put it at the start of the mega CD
lifecycle the genesis was probably
released around 89 maybe a little
earlier it was a standalone console
before this came along and this was just
an extra that fitted onto it it was to
add a second processor to the machine an
additional graphics chip and some better
audio capabilities as well as a cd-rom
drive sequence or an anti CDs worth of
game on there this is a special bit of
kit yeah special bit of kit or games
developers to make the games with so
what's your day job I'm a videogames
programmer I've worked to travelers
tales Crytek and deep silver Dan Buster
Studios worked on about 14 titles so far
it kind of looks like a traditional mega
CD but it's not it's all molded together
and screwed together so it's very much
of a spoke piece of hardware inside it's
got a snazzy host board and on top it's
got a mega CD daughterboard and on top
it's got the Genesis to auto board it's
all very custom wide inside so yeah not
exactly a mega CD inside it's got two
sets of switches one for the sega
genesis side one for the mega CD side
it's got dip switches to configure
things like powell or ntsc region
settings got the SCSI ID for it to plug
into the pc one for each side
it's got switches to enable the main CPU
and the sub c pu so you can turn off the
mega-cd side and just run the Genesis
it's also got this big emulator button
here so that you can either emulate the
CD drive through the PC with a big ISO
card or you can set it to run from the
CD drive itself so you can pop a burn CD
inside and the sides we've got a really
big heatsink is very hot component here
it's also got the line out at the side
rather than the front it's got an SCSI
port threat to PC through a snazaroo
interface card it's also got an emulator
port with a very special cable and
that's for the CD ROM emulator the rest
is pretty standard it's got a scart out
an RF out and the usual audio outputs
from the mega CD and again the bridge
doesn't come open that's that's molded
on so this thing can't be taken apart
and a very annoying little wine
and which is quite loud that kind of
looks a bit aftermarket that fun is it
does a little bit you can tell that
they've used a real Sega Genesis shell
and they've put some special hardware
inside it so there are some holes here
where there used to be ports and there
are no longer what can you do with it
then I mean you tell us why you're shown
it is today I'm going to show off a game
that I've been developing on it for the
past three years in raw 68000 assembly
language so I've got the stazon
interface car to plug it in which is a
big as a lynx chip it's also got what
looks like a battery here but it's
actually the license key to use the
software if you ever use Cubase or
something like that that comes with a
dongle it's a similar thing the knife's
now zoom to logo on the back there so
I'm quite happy I managed to find one of
these I'm going to plug this in I'm
going to fire up my game I'm going to
show you how to use the debugger put the
ISO card in the machine it's just
booting Windows 95 now this is an AMD
k-6 200 megahertz machine it was 5 pound
from a car boot sale it was the only one
I could find that could get the ISO car
to work because the bus had to have
specific timings on it it also fails to
boot one in three times so yeah it's a
bit old and knackered but it does the
job and with this thing I've managed to
make my entire game engine in game so I
won't argue with it as long as it keeps
booting now and again I'm happy with it
and why is it that you have to use an
old machine for this is this just is it
an interface thing or what it is here
before PCI we had ISO which was a big
black slot and this is on the
motherboard this is on the motherboard
yeah of the PC a Sega card is a big
heavy ISO card let's fire it up and I'll
show you some code the drivers already
loaded it's already in it the
autoexec.bat so the statin cards ready
to go it's all plugged into the back of
the development kit Vyra looks like a
suicide cable very old fashioned kind of
cable up yes it's a parallel cable but
it serves a different purpose here so
this is part of the Tanglewood codebase
Tanglewood is a game that i'm releasing
next year on real cartridge for the sega
megadrive and it's code in raw 68000
assembly language I'm going to go and
show a couple of lines of assembly if
we've got here the entry point which the
first line of code that the debugger is
going to run first we're going to
to a connect debugger subroutine because
the development kit it needs the
register set up in a certain way in ease
the CPU vector table set up in a certain
way and because it's a mega CD based kit
we have to restore the horizontal
interrupt which is a special thing you
have to do specifically for this kit so
afterwards we're then ready to go we can
type arbitrary code I'm going to go
ahead and do something mundane here so
if we move a long words worth of data
let's say literal 32 to register d0 then
we move a long word literal 16 to
register d1 and then going to add the
two together with the add opcode so add
long words worth data d0 and d1 together
I'm going to save that so basically what
you're doing is you're going to use some
very basic assembler language to do add
a couple of numbers together but using
the using the real dev kit yeah I'm
going to show you how the debugger works
and how to view the results of that as
well so I'm going to go ahead and build
that I've got a batch file setup ready
it's quite a long command-line to do
this and there we go that's built ready
okay so if I flick on the power first of
all the apt light comes on and the
write-protect goes off so it's written
the ROM ready and then it's ready to go
the screens blank so if I open up the
debugger here this is an old ms-dos
based debugger mostly done with keyboard
shortcuts so I can go to that CPU entry
point function that we had there and
there's the code we just wrote move 32
to d0 move 16 to d1 and then add d0 and
d1 so the first thing we do is reset the
CPUs of hit execution reset processor
and then we can start setting
breakpoints so if I hit f5 that'll set a
breakpoint on that code and I can hit 9
to go that's running the executable
that's hit that break point I've got the
registers window down here so you can
see what's going on
so our first command here is to move 32
to register d0 in hex obviously so if I
step once we could see that d0 changes
to 32 and then move 16 to d1 so we can
see that d1 changes to 16 in hex and
then add the two together so add D 0 to
D 1 and that's going to store the result
in d1
and there we go was that actually
running on that deaf kid that yeah this
executables running on this dev kit with
the debugger attached to it so that we
can set breakpoints and view real-time
values like the memory and the registers
as it's running for people who've not
done much in the word developing so a
breakpoint is where you can sort of
pause the program is it yes where you
can pause the program a specified line
so you can see what the state of the
processor is in at that point in time so
something's going wrong something going
wrong you can break in a specific line
of code and view the memory and see what
happened I've got a demo this is the
main character from my game running
around in Sonic Land this is just a
small demo I used to teach programming
how to set breakpoints how to watch
values etc how to monitor memory it's
just a very small window here where you
can push a thing around with the little
physics engine I've got written I'm not
a developer but it looks quite
complicated laborious is it is it
difficult it is but you can break it
down to very simple steps and you can
learn one thing as time it took me about
three years to learn assembly language
and how to code for the machine but it
all broke down two very simple steps
like I showed you moving one number to
one register another number to another
register and then adding to the together
there are all three very simple steps
and you can build on that from that you
can learn to subtract multiply divide
once you can do that you can code a very
simple player system where you're adding
velocity to a player position etc at
gravity you then can come clamp it to
the the floor height etc so using very
simple op codes like that it doesn't
take that long to get a very simple game
system running the tricky bits working
with the graphics and audio hardware and
here but even then all that can be
broken into similarly simple steps and
do you have to end up keeping a lot of
this information you had them yes and
now I write a blog someone I started
learning 68k assembler
I made sure every line of code I wrote
everything I found out I blogged on my
website so that I can come back to when
I've forgotten bits or I'd messed up uh
needs a back track you did that kind of
like a diary but could anyone else have
a look at that if they want yeah sure
I'll drop it in the description your
game then where are you at with it now I
finished the first level which is split
into three acts and it's got most of the
main mechanics running it's now on
Kickstarter so I've used the demo to try
and generate some hype for the game
there's a rom you can download you can
play using an emulator Windows Mac and
Linux even some handheld consoles have
some emulators see you can put the ROM
in there and play it on there
if you got something like an overdrive
cart which is a flash card that you can
put inside your Mega Drive to put a rom
on you can actually play the game on
your real console at home do you think
there are a lot of people out there
still working on this kind of equipment
I know at least one other developer who
is making a game on cartridge I know one
other person with one of these machines
in down in Australia it's the other
known working kit I know of other than
that is quite a rare quite a rare thing
to do there is a small homeroom commute
either some forums you can look at for
advice and stuff and we'll assume in the
68-hundred was in other machines as well
other devices as well well yeah it was
they were Terry's and amigas based on
the 68k lots of embedded
microcontrollers were based on it was a
very widely used chip does that mean
that a lot of the language that you're
using for this is the same across those
as well or yeah it certainly applies
elsewhere yeah so you could potentially
port things backwards and forwards yeah
you could do yeah the only specialized
parts really the graphics and the sound
hardware those have to be redone but the
core language itself is usable across
multiple machines
we'd like to thank audible.com for
supporting computerphile and if you go
to audible.com slash computerphile
there's a chance to sign up for a 30-day
free trial and download a free audiobook
now today I'd like to recommend the book
that I first listened to as an audiobook
which is the Hobbit back in the day I
had a tape and book and it was very
heavily abridged and every time he got
to the end of a page there was a dinging
sound and you had to turn the page well
fear not go to audible.com you can
listen to that whole unabridged version
of The Hobbit it probably needs no
introduction from me so check out the
Hobbit inaudible com
and thanks once again to them for
supporting computerphile he'll help you
out by giving you his color name changes
to yellow so now that he's yellow he can
glide so you can then get past gaps so
there we go we can fly over that big
gutter continue on but of course time
isn't on your side so it's going to
change